so today we're gonna talk about the
three hidden causes of inflammation and
of all the medications sold in the u.s.
even worldwide
it's the anti-inflammatories that
dominate because so many people are
taking meds for inflammation more than
any other condition and I'm going to
talk about the three hidden causes of
inflammation that you may have not heard
about before okay if we take cortisol
for example cortisol is an adrenal
hormone okay and it is the hormone in
the body that is supposed to stop
inflammation it's supposed to inhibit
inflammatory conditions now think about
any condition that involves inflammation
whether it's autoimmune or just pain and
inflammation in general they always use
prednisone cortisol cream cortisone
injections it's all cortisol but of
course it's synthetic and yes it comes
with a package but the point is that
cortisol stops inflammation now if that
is true then chronic inflammatory
conditions must be a state of low
cortisol right makes a logical sense but
if that's true how do you explain all
the people who have arthritis serious
inflammation they go get tested and they
have high cortisol or normal cortisol
okay
I mean look look at this this is a sip
encyclopedia medical illustrations
endocrine system volume four on page 84
okay there's a condition called
Cushing's syndrome okay right here so
this is a very common condition it's in
a situation where you have too much
cortisol okay so I'm just going to go
through the symptoms yeah belly fat you
have major inflammation throughout the
body you have sleep problems high blood
pressure gastric acidity heartburn you
have a lowered immune system you have
excessive thoughts you keep thinking
thinking thinking can't turn it off you
have a low tolerance to stress but you
you have a lot of inflammation the body
from high cortisol why is that that is
because of this
and I did another video on insulin
resistance and I told you that I was
going to do a video on cortisol
resistance there's a condition called
cortisol resistance in which the
receptor for cortisol is downgraded in
other words it doesn't receive that well
anymore so we have the adrenal gland
that produces cortisol it's supposed to
go into a receptor and if there's too
much of that hormone being pumped out
because the person is under chronic
stress whatever then the receptor is
going to downgrade and protect the body
against the excess amount of course all
because it's it's not good for the body
to have too much cortisol your side
effects let me just look at prednisone
the side effects from prednisone it's
like it's crazy so the body will protect
itself especially the inside of the cell
and certain delicate tissues by creating
resistance okay the problem is then that
blocks the return communication the
negative feedback loop and so now the
adrenal doesn't get the message that
disconnected so the body keeps making
more and more cortisol so now we have a
situation where we have certain parts of
the body that have a low cortisol and
other parts of the body that have high
cortisol this explains the confusion
people have because the symptoms for
high are almost identical to the
symptoms with low now there is another
condition called Addison's disease okay
which is very rare where your basically
your adrenals aren't functioning anymore
and you're very very thin your skin
becomes tan or darker but you have very
serious right can't fight it serious
immune problems okay but the point is
that when you have too much cortisol it
can produce a state where you get a lot
of chronic inflammation why because you
develop the resistance okay resistance
in the cell now
what I want to talk about is what causes
this cortisol resistance it's chronic
stress okay and I want to increase your
awareness and what that means it could
also be being lonely for a long period
of time okay that can increase cortisol
or having lost sense
okay a loss of a loved one or a
threatened loss okay I mean when my son
was six months old he developed
infantile botulism okay
that's a pretty serious disease it kills
all the nerves only twenty children a
year get it it's very rare and he got it
okay it created a lot of stress with our
family he's doing fine now
but the point is that that's a threat of
a loss okay so you have losses you have
surgeries trauma mental stress
especially if you're not exercising okay
no sleep I mean I remember myself I had
12 years where I did not sleep very well
there was nights I didn't sleep for one
minute I stayed up all that long
so that actually really wore out my
adrenals in fact that's why I'm doing
this video right now because I had this
condition the point is that there are
all these triggers that can happen and a
lot of people have chronic stress and
that creates this problem right here
and eventually they develop chronic
inflammation in the NIP road on a
medication okay here's the problem when
you lose the function of course all you
also lose the control of your immune
system you become more susceptible to
viruses viruses go in like a rocket ship
okay and that leads me to another cause
of inflammation and that's a chronic
infection okay so now chronic infection
could also come from taking a lot of
antibiotics it could come from your
entire gut being imbalance because you
don't have enough flora it can come from
many things it could also come from an
adrenal situation as well but a lot of
people have this chronic inflammatory
condition because they have microbes
growing in the body in excessive amounts
it could be also it could be viral
it could be bacterial it could be yeast
it could be nano bacteria
it could be Michael plasma and then one
day they might discover it because they
take an antibiotic and they feel great
well that's just a big clue that you
have microbes growing in your body and
that's what's creating the inflammation
maybe in a joint or in a different part
of the body these people usually also
have chronic fatigue syndrome what I'm
going to recommend is to take a natural
herbal
antibiotic and I had videos on there
more than an actual antibiotic because
you're gonna just make the problem worse
over time now a lot of times these
crossover you can have a problem of
cortisol and problem with infections or
problem with infections and can stress
out the adrenals and cause high levels
of cortisol but when you lose the
adrenal function okay and you can have
high cortisol and it's just not working
you open the door for viruses and also
you can open the door for getting
autoimmune diseases okay it's it's
nearly always related to some stress
event that comes right before that
autoimmune condition okay so now that
you're trying with that let's talk about
the third cause of inflammation which is
basically insulin resistance you may
already know this I have a lot of videos
on this I've been talking about this
I'll put some links down below but if
you're new to my channel and you don't
know this this is going to be very
important insulin resistance is the
condition where you're producing too
much insulin okay that excess amount
causes a lot of inflammation in the body
plus the fact that this is triggered by
your high carbohydrate diet and your
frequency of eating okay so if you eat
too frequently and you have too many
carbs you are going to eventually get
inflammation so what you need to do is
get on the program to reduce your carbs
and do in a minute fasting there's a
link down below for that but if I had a
chronic inflammation okay I would be on
a healthy keto plan I would do in a
minute fasting that's gonna bring it
right down I'd probably if I had any
possible infection going on I would take
an herbal antibiotic some natural ones
like garlic on a regular basis and I
would do everything I can to get out of
my stress situation okay improve the
stress and focus on getting more sleep
go for long walks and whatever is
triggering this trying to minimize the
damage control and you would find out
that your inflammation would drop very
very fast okay so go ahead and try it
and give me your comments below I'll see
in the next video so if you want more
knowledge on how to create a healthy
body subscribe now and get daily
notification
daily notifications that sounds weird
well I'll just remind you on a daily
basis how about that